[Musique]
tel bourdonne produisent du miel comme
toutes les abeilles mais celles ci sont
très différentes
[Musique]
fanny arbillot parle avec une affection
maternelle de ses abeilles mais l'ippon
mais l'icône à béquilles plus exactement
ses abeilles standard qui ne semble pas
très dérangé quand on ouvre leur ruche
c'est abeilles élevé depuis des
millénaires par les mayas étaient en
voie de disparition
sa renaissance on la doit en grande
partie à ce français passionné
d'apiculture depuis son enfance établi
au mexique devenu hôtelier stéphane
palmyre et entend parler de la fameuse
abeilles maya il se met à sa recherche
pas facile
on avait trouvé trois colonies et ça en
2010 donc il ya une dizaine d'années 3
juste trois colonies et qui était
empressé dé pas piqué qui avait ça
depuis des générations les ruches sont à
l'arrière de son hôtel au milieu d'une
végétation foisonnante
avec sa fondation mais l'ippon amaya il
commence la récupération génétique
l'idée c'était de reproduire des
colonies pour pouvoir les multiplier il
nous fallait quand même patrimoine
génétique un peu conséquence on a
reproduit
en maille à cette abeille se nomme sunan
cab littéralement la vraie dame tombée
de son tout calme
lesquelles elles savent qu'on est pas le
monde
ça c'est la vision un peu cosmic vision
de là de là à dire que les anciennes
civilisations maya en copier la
structure du couvain des abeilles en
érigeant leur pyramide les mails ippon
ont eu durant des millénaires un rôle
central dans la vie et la mythologie des
civilisations maya
amusé ncab c'est la divinité des
abeilles on peut voir sa représentation
dans ce temple de tôle aux mains tête
vers le bas on l'appelait le le
descendant mettre de la vie de l'énergie
vitale associé à la fécondité
bienveillant pacifique comme les
abeilles milipol également divinité de
l'écriture du calendrier surtout de la
médecine dans la tradition maya les 500
ont toujours été les ailes d'un dépôt là
il le donne à la mer ou pendant
l'accouchement plus tard il le donne aux
bébés donc il ya toute une utilisation
ancestrales pour toute une série de
préparation
la renaissance de la bei mais l'ipo navy
d'intéresser l'université interculturel
maya de felipe carillo puerto
label mythique figure en bonne place sur
les murales de l'université où
l'enseignement se fait en maya
[Musique]
non loin dans le parc un sanctuaire
apicole y ajoute hashcash qui veut dire
forêt bien aimé où se trouvent les
ruches telle qu'elle était exploité par
les anciens mayas à aurora show l'alpa
dirige le programme de recherche les
multiples et de formation d'apiculteurs
les mails ippon sont des abeilles
tropicale qu'on retrouve au mexique et
en amérique centrale le monde des mayas
ceux ci l'ont répandue jusqu'à cuba mais
on trouve aussi de sept sortes
d'abeilles au brésil et même en
australie les mails ippon diffère
sensiblement de l'abm la plus courante
la piste mellifères on reconnaît les
ouvrières à leurs yeux bleus les mâles
et la reine ont les yeux noirs estime
ivan kavanagh qui
le miel se trouvent dans ces amphores
bombay on peut le voir en les persans en
quelques secondes des abeilles vont s'en
nourrir rien ne se perd autre
particularité la gardienne à l'entrée de
la ruche qui s'écarte à chaque entrée ou
sortie
le retour à la rue des abeilles qui ont
été dérangés est toujours un grand
spectacle
reste à explorer les mystères de l'âme
et lipton de son miel et de sa propre
police ces ruches sont issus des
premières reproductions de stéphane
palmieri qui chez lui s'intéresse à
d'autres variétés de milipol il y en a
47 dans le yucatan les nous manque
énormément de sciences quoi surtout ce
qui est avec native on n'a même pas la
caractérisation du miel de mélina donc
la science on s'apprête à l'explorer à
l'université maya ou ont fini de
construire le plus grand centre de
recherches apicoles d'amérique latine
on s'apprête à recevoir le matériel des
laboratoires qui se consacreront aux
analyses et des salles de classe
les familles en gouaille au qui a été
formé à l'université dit que l'élevage
2000 ippon est assez facile mais il faut
se contenter d'une seule récolte par an
avec une production d'un litre par uche
par année contre 35 litres pour des
abeilles ordinaire avec quatre récoltes
par an ce miel est évidemment beaucoup
plus cher
l'agronome reçu au vide à lundi que le
miel 2000 ippon et plus riche un peu
plus acide plus liquides sa saveur varie
selon les plantes que la bei butine
selon les régions
elle veut mettre son miel sur le marché
ainsi que d'autres sortes de miel en
évitant les intermédiaires
l'inconvénient son prix mais il semble y
avoir un marché
cet apiculteur vend son propre miel et
celui d'autres producteurs indépendants
mais très peu de miel 2000 ippon il est
au moins cinq fois plus cher le miel de
milipol doit encore être reconnu et
protégé des contrefaçons par une sorte
d'appellation contrôlée bien j -p il
faut aussi faire connaître sa valeur
culturelle et patrimoniale millénaire la
mi-mars c'est perdre you estamos
d'atteindre la salle
autre menace pour la melli pon commune à
toutes les abeilles du monde la
déforestation les cultures transgéniques
et les pesticides qui atteignent des
sommets inquiétant dans la péninsule du
yucatan